so kelly we have several different
options on what type of browser we use
does it matter from a from a safety and
privacy point of view
yeah there are a couple factors that you
might want to think about that make a
browser potentially safer
so one thing that's important is how
frequently the browser updates and
ideally automatically updates so
attackers are constantly looking for
gaps and holes where they can press
their advantage and browser
manufacturers should be looking to close
those
gaps and protect your computer by
releasing updates with security updates
in them another thing you might want to
consider is what built-in security
protections your browser has so
browsers like chrome use my team service
safe browsing to offer malware phishing
unwanted software protections and so
that's basically your first line of
defense we'll be looking out for you to
see if there is a dangerous uh site and
warn you about it so you have that
before it even touches your computer
um there are also other things like
chrome has protections against dangerous
extensions that
are offered as well as things like a
feature that looks for passwords that
might have been leaked so you know that
you can update your password so thinking
about what does your browser offer in
terms of built-in security protections
can be an important role as well super
useful